my name is Bryan Cranston and my
favorite movie is on the waterfront on
the waterfront deals with the rights of
workers working class people they're not
special people in any regard really
there they're just honest guys is trying
to support their families there was so
much honor within the tapestry of the
message you know you draw a line of
morality and what side of that do you
stand on I think that's that's a the
deeper message that on the waterfront
talks about the scene in the taxi cab
with Marlon Brando Steiger he's talking
about what could have been I could have
been a contender I could have been
somebody instead of a bum Brando is
thinking he could have been a champion
fighter instead as he says he's a bum I
think every actor wants to be able to be
in control of their destiny and when you
first start out you're basically taking
any job you can just to make a living
and there's there's honor that this
that's fine now I feel like I want to do
things that challenge me the latest film
left on is called Trumbo that's the life
of Dalton Trumbo he was a well-respected
prolific screenwriter back in the 40s
and the 50s he was also a communist that
was his political belief and he was
persecuted for that no studio will ever
employed a member of the Communist Party
Dalton Trumbo was a man who cared deeply
about workers rights and on the
waterfront was really a cautionary tale
about how to navigate those choppy
waters of employment people who were
being persecuted for their political
ideals as Dalton Trumbo himself was
persecuted and then prosecuted for it
you're willing to lose all of this just
to do the right thing when I saw on the
waterfront there was social relevance to
it I felt all these emotions just moving
around in me very very very impactful my
name is Bryan Cranston
I love movies that's a wrap
you